[Musique]
cela ressemble à un musée imaginaire
avec le degré zéro des images l'artiste
plasticien belge patrick corillon
retrache le passage des hommes j'ai
essayé d'aborder les images mais autant
suivant les images du monde qu'on peut
regarder d'une façon très physique les
images qui viennent nous comment regarde
le monde mais aussi toutes les images
mentales qu'on a c'est à dire comment se
projette dans le monde comment nous nous
pouvons nous projeter ou projeter des
autres où toutes les images inconsciente
et c'est un petit peu ce point
d'équilibré qui a entre image extérieure
et puis tous nos paysages mentaux des
photographies en cuivre délavé des
objets insolites exposés de manière
brute
l'artiste entre en contact avec les gens
par des histoires dessinées ou sculptées
tout est totalement imaginaire donc
toutes ces histoires sont 100% fictifs
quand j'imagine des objets du folklore
marins ou des peintres la peau ou même
ici du peintre le caravage tout est
totalement imaginaire l'aimé histoire et
peuvent dans as un corner sous forme de
dessin sous forme de sculptures sous
forme de dessins animés des histoires
incarner son personnage fétiche oscar
serti est un écrivain déficients visuels
parfois accompagnée de catherine de ces
listes une pianiste déchu un jeu de rôle
pour cet artiste ce personnage avait une
bonne amie s'appelait catherine dos et
nice ils se sont séparés mais ils ont
continué tout le réseau leur vie à se
téléphoner
et j'explique que même ce centre est
jamais revenu quand il téléphonait
chacun au bout pendant qu'ils
téléphonaient griffonnait
un retour aux sources pour l'artiste le
degré zéro des images est une première
pour patrick corillon dans un centre
d'art contemporain depuis dix ans
[Musique]